the rumor is that Mark Fergus may be the
man to lead Stargate into its next
Generation but is Mark Fergus a Stargate
fan is he the man to lead the new
franchise welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
when I drop the news exclusively to you
side trackers that Mark Fergus was
interested in potentially running the
Stargate franchise and that we like to
find out through Jenny stiven a MGM
Insider that works a lot with dial the
gate and gateworld that actually Mark
Fergus was one that asked for the
Stargate project a lot of people
immediately asked me the question is
Mark Fergus actually a Stargate fan is
he the man to lead us forwards into a
new franchise or is he just another Alex
kurtzman somebody that's going to take
our beloved franchise in the wrong
direction well thanks to a couple of my
insiders I've been able to actually
answer this question some of the people
I speak to have been whispering in my
ear once again and it seems that there
was a meeting in very late November or
early December that meeting was sort of
like a developmental thing the it was
following the initial pitches and it was
a series of other meetings so they had
to sort of flash around a few ideas that
Amazon and MGM Executives had and that
Mark Fergus had it was a chance for Mark
Fergus to ask a few questions and vice
versa and apparently in that
conversation some marketing people
brought up some information they'd got
from a selected questionnaire that
they'd sent out to Amazon customers now
I told you about this questionnaire back
and I think it was July or August that
Amazon had actually sent this
questionnaire out as quite a small
number
um a select number of Amazon customers
and it was asking basically do you watch
Stargate if a new Stargate series came
along what would you want to see blah
blah blah and from that information they
got a lot of requests for a conclusion
to Stargate Universe now I'm going to
talk about that a bit more in the next
video so apparently in the meeting it
basically went like this a marketing
executive brought up Stargate Universe
asked Mark Fergus what he thought about
it
Mark Fergus then sort of started talking
about Stargate Universe in quite a lot
of detail he name dropped a few of the
main actors including Robert Carlisle
and a few others and Lou Diamond
Phillips included and he even then
talked about how disappointed he was to
see it get
um canceled at the end of season two
apparently he talked in quite a lot of
detail apparently for about half an hour
about where he would have liked to have
seen the series go if it had got into
third or maybe even a fourth season
but then most interestingly he started
talking about the planet Builders now
I've asked Matt our bearded friend to do
a video about the planet Builders next
week now it's not a culture or a society
we know a great deal about but we did
get to see them in a couple of episodes
of Stargate Universe but from what we
saw they might actually be the most
powerful species we saw in the Stargate
franchise I would argue that potentially
even more powerful than the atlanteans
the Ancients themselves now Mark Fergus
didn't just know about this again he
talked about it for quite some time he
talked about how this species needed to
be padded out more and that maybe they
would have an opportunity to do that if
given the chance
so is Mark Fergus a fan of Stargate well
when asked about this by marketing
people that probably have no idea what
these answers on these questionnaires
meant when people kept asking for a
conclusion to Stargate Universe Mark
Fergus jumped on it and wouldn't shut up
apparently this meeting was supposed to
be two hours and he talked about
Stargate Universe for most of it so is
Mark Fergus a Stargate fan yes is Mark
Fergus the man to take us forward with
this franchise well
after we've seen what he did with the
expanse after we've seen what he's doing
with lots of other projects that he's
done we know that he is a very fine
writer and we know that him and Hawk
ospi and his penguin and a Parker
company are incredibly good at
developing TV series keeping them
reasonably simple but intelligent and we
know that he has that creative ability
to do something in line with what we're
used to from Stargate as well then I
would say oh God hell yes this man is
not only the right man to push his Thor
to Stargate if they're not going to go
with Brad Wright I'm going to argue he
may be the only man to push us forward
with Stargate the Penguin and a Parker
team and this is a team effort by the
way apparently there's four or five
people from um penguin and Parker and
well my source tells me that actually
they were doing most of the talking and
the executives were just sort of sat on
the other side of it and sort of nodding
and smiling sounds like it could be a
problem well
up against a pretty bad guys yeah not so
pretty
overdressed yes so the MGM the Amazon
marketing people and people in that
meeting were potentially not Stargate
fans but that's not important they've
just got to write a check the team on
the other side of the desk the Penguin
and the Parker team they're the ones
that are important they're the ones that
are going to be doing the work and
they're the ones that seem to know what
they're talking about when it comes to
Stargate now that means they've done
their research which is important but
for me for him to jump on such an
obscure species from the Stargate
Universe a species that we only really
got to see twice says a lot now if he'd
have started talking about the furlings
I'd have been impressed if you'd have
started talking about the Gold World I'd
have been like okay unless he starts
talking about it in great detail you
know you could just watch a couple of
episodes of style getting talk
intelligently about the furlings and the
gold if you'd have known about the
replicators fine but he knew about one
of the most obscure species or races
that we got to see in all of Stargate
and he talked about it intelligently for
15 to 20 minutes
so does this improve my confidence in
the plan for Stargate moving forward if
the negotiations can get done and if
Amazon can actually decide what the hell
to do with Stargate yes yes yes
Penguin in a park are 100 the team to
make this franchise great again and to
wake up the sleeping giant to sci-fi
[Applause]
guys get in the comments please don't
tell me what you think about this very
interesting news that happened now a
couple of months ago it's only just
getting to me but you know unfortunately
information has to be carefully
disseminated to you guys because we do
have to protect the sources but I'd love
to know what you think about this
because to me I think it's great I can't
I can't tell you how much I love that
not only is this guy a gator basically
but he's actually somebody that probably
knows almost as much about stargaters
maybe Brad Wright which is amazing but
get in the comments and tell me exactly
what you're thinking if you are new to
the channel don't forget to like
subscribe hit that Bell notification
share the video wherever the hell you
like if you want to become a fully
fledged side tracker and support the
channel even more hit the join button
and don't forget that there are links to
all of our other things like the Discord
server the Twitter account the Facebook
group the nine Chevrons website and
everything else all in the descriptions
go and please check that out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign